the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we have a class car here object as as
usual the init method here takes himself
as usual a WN daddy so so car gets
initialized with two parameters
and we assign the wheels data attribute
to the first one and the door's data
attribute to the second one and then
we're going to also assign a color data
attribute to be the empty string so I'm
giving you four choices here and the
question says which of the above is a
getter method for the number of wheels
okay so get our method is something
that's going to get a data attribute a
method is really just a function so of
course we're going to have DF get Wheels
is a good name for it since the method
for this class we have to have self in
the parameters so we know it's going to
be between C and D and so then what are
we going to return the first one is
going to return wheels which in this
particular case is just going to be a
variable that we haven't defined what
it's a variable a getter returns a data
attribute over particular instance so we
actually have to say self dot if we want
to return a data attribute of an
instance as opposed to just a regular
variable so the correct answer is d
great job